يبدو بان الصراع في اوكرانيا بدا ياخذ
اشكالا مختلفه بعيدا عن القتال المتواصل
بين مقاتلي الجيشين فالهجمات لم تعد تقتصر
على المجموعه العسكريه او القتاليه
المنظمه بل باتت تتم عن طريق مجموعات
تخريبيه حسب الادعاءات الروسيه هذا ما
اعلن عنه حاكم مقاطعه بيرياس الكسندر
بوجوماس الذي قال ان مجموعه تخريبيه
اوكرانيه على حد قوله قامت بالتسلل الى
منطقه كليموفيسكا في مقاطعه بريانس على
الحدود الروسيه الاوكرانيه اضاف المسؤول
الروسي ان تلك المجموعه نفذت عمليات
الاجراميه وارهابيه في المنطقه مخلفه قتلى
وجرحى
التي سردها المسؤول فان العمليه تمت بشكل
مخطط باحكام فالمجموعه التخريبيه على حد
قوله تسللت من الحدود الاوكرانيه الى قريه
لوبيتشان الروسيه وقامت بعدها باطلاق
النار على السيارات من تلك المنطقه مما
ادى الى مقتل شخص واصابه طفل يبلغ من
العمر 10 سنوات بجروح كما قامت المجموعه
باحتجاز سته مواطنين كرهائن في مقاطعه
بريال
وياتي هذا الهجوم ليضاف الى سلسله من
الهجمات الاوكرانيه التي باتت تستهدف
العمق الروسي مؤخرا حيث كانت القوات
الاوكرانيه قد شنت هجوما على مقاطعه
بواسطه مسيره تم اسقاطها ما ادى الى
اشتعال النيران في مبنى سكني في قريه
سوشاني كذلك تعرضت قريه لوما كوفكا في
منطقه ستار دوبسكي لقصف اوكراني بقذائف
الهول ولم تسجل اصابات لكن تم تسجيل اضرار
في المباني كما كان حاكم منطقه كورسك
رومان ستروفويت قد قال او افاد بقصف
القوات الاوكرانيه لقريه تتكينو ما اسفر
عن وقوع ضحايا
اعلن جهاز الامن الفيدراليه الروسيه انه
طرد القوه الاوكرانيه التي هاجمت برياسك
الى داخل الاراضي الاوكرانيه واضاف الجهاد
الامني الروسي انه تجنب مواجهه
الاوكرانيين على اراضي روسيا للحفاظ على
ارواح المدنيين مشيرا الى انه بدا قصفا
مدفعيا عن المجموعه الاوكرانيه في موقع
وجودهم بعد طردهم